all right Monica thanks so much in that
rowdy crowd now we're over what just
over about 40 minutes away from the
polls closing in Mississippi as
Republican Governor Tate Reeves tries to
win a second term against a challenger
Democrat Brandon Presley yes cousin of
Elvis and what better place for him to
do his final push then right here on the
angle Governor Reeves joins me now all
right go uh what's your message for the
people of Mississippi tonight a lot of
folks watching uh this race are like why
would this be that close in Mississippi
and your answer to that
is well the the reason for that is that
80% of Brandon Presley's money has come
from California New York and Washington
DC literally liberal billionaires
spending millions and millions of
dollars in Mississippi over12 million my
opponent will spend in the state of
Mississippi this year 80% of which came
from out of state but we're confident
that people are going to show up at the
polls today we've got 40 more minutes to
get out so if you're in Mississippi and
you're you haven't been to the polls yet
go vote that's the that's honor of
Veteran today and get out and and vote
uh and vote to keep Mississippi red
because we know what blue State
Governors did in blue States during the
global pandemic and what they would do
to our state because that $10 million
that he received from California New
York that ain't charity they don't just
want to change the governor of
Mississippi they want to change they
don't want to just change the governor
they want to change
Mississippi well the New York times
wrote this of your opponent Mr Presley
saying Presley's campaign has been built
on a bet that his human touch and
populist platform can forge a coalition
of black and liberal de Centrist white
voters some disaffected Republicans
among them that is robust enough enough
for him to win Governor he's trying to
posit himself as a kind of a Democrat
populist maybe trying to pull some of
the Maga crowd his way does that
ultimately fly in your
state well what I would tell you is what
older gentleman told me on the campaign
Trail about 10 days ago he said look
what you need to say in every group is
if a man stands up and tells you he's a
Democrat the best thing you can do is to
believe him the fact of the matter is my
opponent supported Hillary Clinton in
2016 my opponent supported Joe Biden in
20120 and so for anybody in Mississippi
or anyone watching tonight uh that
thinks Joe Biden's doing a great job for
America then they can elect this guy to
run Mississippi but if you don't believe
that and I don't think very many
mississippians do we got 40 more minutes
to get out to the polls and and vote for
True conservative leadership in the
great state of Mississippi well
Mississippi is an upand cominging State
a lot of friends have moved there and
are investing there Governor we uh wish
you the best of luck tonight we're going
to be watching hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else